en ucrania la guerra está llevando a la
población más afectada a buscar
soluciones alternativas para sobrevivir
económicamente al conflicto bélico es el
caso de andrew min un agente
inmobiliario que ya no tiene clientes
por la crisis que sufre su sector sus
costes si por supuesto es muy difícil
ahora por eso he empezado a trabajar en
el sector de las tecnologías ya que
nuestro ejército necesita este tipo de
sustento
que ha sido la economía de guerra
posmoderna de la ucrania de hoy la que
le ha dado otra oportunidad a andrew
juan b
un día estaba con el teléfono y el otro
tenía un dron esa es mi especialidad
ahora
elena tampoco tiene a quien vender sus
prendas hechas a mano esta vendedora
callejera suele tener buenos ingresos
con la antaño boyante industria del
turismo pero ya no hay turistas y
también su hija ha perdido el trabajo
por la godzilla
tienen que pagar las expensas la
electricidad del agua y vive por su
cuenta pero ahora ha conseguido un nuevo
empleo online
la economía ucraniana mucho más que la
de rusia está sufriendo enormemente por
la guerra las estimaciones indican que
el pib de este país caerá entre un 35 y
un 50 por ciento este año lastrado en
particular por las industrias más
afectadas como los servicios el turismo
y el sector metalúrgico
según un blog dormir dubrovsky analista
del instituto que hace un problema es el
gran número de desplazados que abandonan
sus hogares y su trabajo y no encuentran
un empleo en su nuevo destino aunque hay
excepciones
la pandemia ha sido una especie vacuna
porque mucha gente se ha acostumbrado a
trabajar a distancia
distan clip un paseo por la capital de
ucrania sub terrazas semi vacías las
tantas tiendas cerradas reflejan el
impacto devastador que el conflicto está
teniendo para este país un lastre que
para los ciudadanos que se adaptan a
estos tiempos difíciles
es el inicio de una nueva vida